hi my name is Yama I'm very excited to
be here so thanks for having me and
thank you all for coming I'm going to
talk about songs analysis and show you a
little bit of the huge amount of
information we can extract from it
specifically regarding repetition in the
lyrics so first I'm going to talk a
little bit about me and my part where I
work then we're going to see the
motivation to discuss repetition we'll
define some building blocks that we can
work with we'll talk about what counts
as repetition and how we extract a
repetition based structure will look at
different song structures and see what
we can learn from them and then we'll
talk a little bit about music and
finally about our models I'm a data
scientist at my part I'm researching
lyrical and musical song features I have
a bachelors in mathematics and physics
from tel-aviv University where I also
play the saxophone in the Tao wind band
so apparently there's a problem in the
music industry where they don't have
enough good songwriters of course some
singers write their own music but there
are a few famous songwriters and even
though I say famous I'm guessing you
haven't heard of them
for example max Martin he's a Swedish
producer and songwriter the one
songwriter of the Year award for 10 out
of the last 20 years he wrote hit songs
for Britney Spears and seeing Katy Perry
pink maroon 5 Taylor Swift Justin
Timberlake and a few more and if a
singer can get someone to guide the
right good good music for him they might
be in trouble now these days if you
write a great song for a Dianna Grande
and you want to send it to her you need
to find that friend that her roommates
cousin knows someone that works for
Ariana and hope that your song doesn't
end up in the trash before anyone even
listen to it so my part to the rescue
obviously with the power of AI we have a
platform that connects songwriters with
performing artists and for each artist
that works with us you can see some of
them in the colored photos like ever
Smith una Mars Valley PAH Kelly Clarkson
we build a benchmark of songs that is
composed of these artists songs or songs
to reflect if they were hers and then we
extract a lot of features lyrical
structural harmonic melodic and our
models are trained on this benchmark on
the art side they get sort of tinder of
songs skip the part we prioritize the
songs that are submitted to the artist
according to the models predictions and
then they see their teen their songs in
Israel for example we had a pilot with
with if really there he asked his fans
to write songs for him and more than
1,000 songs were submitted my part
prioritized the songs so even he only
went through the top of the list and
already found relevant stuff that he
liked eventually anonymous songwriters
got personal feedback form every and an
opportunity to cooperate with them
without having to go through a reality
show I'm assuming there's a few
songwriters here as well so don't forget
to go to a website after the Meetup and
submit your song to your favorite artist
now let's talk motivation why should we
talk about repetition because it matters
this graph was taken from an essay
written by Colin Morris called our pop
lyrics getting more repetitive there's
also a nice TED talk Morris analyzed
data set of 15,000 songs that charted on
the Billboard Hot 100 between 1960 and
2015 that's the x-axis now the Billboard
Hot 100 is our the record chart
published by Billboard magazine it's
based on sales radio play and online
streaming in the United States and it's
a way for us to look at the best songs
the blue line represents all songs
meaning the top 100
and the orange line represents the top
ten
how did Colin measure that
repetitiveness he actually did that by
compressing the lyrics file and looking
at the ratio of the size of the lyrics
file before an effort after the
compression these are the percentages in
the y-axis compression is a nice measure
because it uses repeated sequences so
it's not only about which words repeated
but also about their order now we can
see that the songs are getting more and
more repetitive throughout the years and
you might have heard that before usually
as criticism but if we can also see that
the best songs those that reach the top
10 were on average more repetitive than
the rest in every year from 1960 to 2015
and that gap is widening
so I think we can agree that repetition
is a good measure to talk about and even
if you don't agree that's still what we
were going to talk about and now will
define some building blocks that we can
use throughout to talk so we'll define a
segment in the lyrics by the blank line
separator and by default we'll call
every segment of verse and we'll define
the chorus as the segment of the lyrics
that repeats the most the same way we
will define a sentence in the lyrics as
a new line we don't care about
punctuation for that matter and we'll
define a refrain as the sentence that
repeats the most so let's look at an
example in this song you're so vain by
Carly Simon we can see four segments in
the lyrics one of them repeats twice so
we call it the chorus
that's the segment in pink and in the
chorus we have a line that repeats twice
which is you're so vain so in total it
repeats four times which is the maximum
amount of repetition for our line here
so we call it a refrain so how do we
define our petition of a sentence or
four of a segment we know it shouldn't
be perfect repetition because we don't
want one during coma or an extra word to
call off the segments
and even if the chorus for example in
one of its appearances and with a few
more don't you it should still be
recognized as the chorus right and maybe
if will consider the sentences you
probably think this song is about you
and I'll bet you think this song is
about you and similar then it will be
the refrain in the song so we need to
find an algorithm that checks the
similarity of two strings and a
threshold it says when do we call two
strings similar so we ended up with
Levenstein distance which is a string
metric that measures the number of
characters you need to add delete or
replace to transform one string into the
other for example if you would like to
transform Justin Timberlake into Justin
Bieber all you have to do is replace the
T with the B to get Justin Timberlake
place
the M we didn't eat to get Justin Beiber
leg and then delete the letters Lak and
eat to get Justin Bieber and if we give
every action a score of 1 and remember
that replacing is actually two actions
adding and deleting we get that the
Timberlake Bieber distance is 8 now we
can just calculate 1 minus the score
divided by the total length of the
strings and for Justin Bieber in Justin
Timberlake we get 73% similarity and
after consulting our lyrics experts and
testing a little bit we get to the
threshold of 70% meaning if two segments
or sentences are 70% similar then we
consider them similar so for that matter
we consider the Justin's similar so back
to your so vain that we saw earlier the
sentences you probably think the song is
about you and I'll bet you think this
song is about you are considered similar
according to a 70 are 70% percent
threshold but you're so vain still
repeats more times so the final
repetition based structure is for this
part of the song is the school's vales
coast where the refrain does not appear
in the verses and if we look at some
other song structures
we can see that for example in Whitney
Houston's greatest love of all we have
three segments and each one of them
repeats twice so by the definition we
gave we can't call any of them chorus
now in this song the refrain is the
greatest love of all which is also
similar to because the greatest love of
all I found the greatest love of all and
it is the greatest love of all so the
structure is type 1 verse type 2 verse
type 3 verse and again from the top
where the refrain appears only in type 3
verse and another example is shape of
you by ed sheeran where we have two
segments repeating the same number of
times and in that case we will call the
first one pre coast and the second one
chorus and in this song the refrain is
I'm in love with your body and it
appears only in the course so the
structure is very cows cows and again
from the top
so actually the structure we extract is
not based only on repetition as we saw
here but also on Rhymes and syllables we
differentiate between verses that have
different rhyming structures for example
a verse with no rhymes compared to a
verse where every other line rhymes and
between verses with different stressed
syllable structures meaning words
distress in the words we know in Hebrew
as Mill L and Milka and after we combine
all of that we get the final lyrical
structure now we would imagine that
music is a creative world with the
neverending inspiration and unique ideas
but actually not only the lyrics are
full of repetition like we saw but most
of the song of the songs are built the
same way from both lyrical and musical
point of view they're repeating the same
structure this pie chart shows the
structures of a few hundred songs and as
you can see the blue Park represents
more than half of the songs it are built
the same way as shape of you vales
plecos goes the second and third most
common structures that you can see in
red and yellow are various cohost vales
ghost with a small difference between
them
and this distribution is of the
existence of a refrain in 10,000 songs
70% of them have a single sentence with
the highest number of repetitions and
the double refrain is when you have two
sentences repeating the most and that
appears in only 13% of the songs so if
you want your favorite artist choosing
your song make sure it has a pre coast
and I refrain in it now we can just
apply this whole process of analysis on
the music right and extract features
regarding the repetition of musical
segments phrases bars chords notes so
yes and no first we need to separate the
song into two components the melody and
the Harmony the Harmony is the chords
you play on your guitar or your keyboard
and the melody is the notes you're
singing the separation is done using
frequency and amplitude analysis and
then we need to transcribe the harmony
and the melody into data we can work
with in that case that means time stamp
and note frequency then we can use some
of the logic we used for the lyrical
features other features that are unique
to music include the melodic range of a
song which is the range between the
highest and the lowest note and this is
also a main characteristic for an artist
when people mentioned Freddie Mercury's
huge vocal range they're talking about
four octaves with compared to Taylor
Swift for example that has a range of
around two octaves which is about the
average vocal range and another feature
this time from the harmony is simply the
percentage of unique chords you can see
examples for that in plenty of youtube
videos that show how you can play the
state now you can play dozens of songs
with the same four chords now everything
we mentioned up till now is
pre-processing and feature extraction
and now we need to find the right model
for our problem now since linguistics
and music theory are both classical
fields full of rules and definitions we
have a lot of features we know
be useful and we don't want to lose
their meaning through dimension
reduction for example and we want to
have labels because our classes are not
necessarily clustered here's a
visualization of our embedded songs for
four different classes two singers and
two bands and as we can see it could be
that a class will include two data
points that are far from one another
if one artist has two songs in different
styles like why don't we that is mostly
clustered at the top right corner but
also has a few songs on the left side
and on the on the other hand it could be
the two data points that are very close
to one another are a part of two
different classes if two artists have
songs that are very similar like our two
singers that are mixed on the left side
so the distribution of the data points
is not enough to define the classes and
this is why we want labels making this
into a classification problem now to
wrap things up and since I know you love
repetition I'm going to go back to the
my part flow now that we're more
comfortable with the analysis we're
doing and the problem we're dealing with
so let's say the Spice Girls reunite and
they're coming to my part for art
sourcing their people are building a
benchmark for them they go we want them
to be Old Spice Girls Meets Beyonce at
the summer beach party and they give us
a bunch of songs that match that vibe
next step is feature extraction all the
lyrical structural monic and melodic
feature features are extracted from the
benchmark songs then the benchmark is
added as a new class to the training
data and our models are trained we use
an ensemble of classifiers random
forests nearest neighbor extra boost
neural network and a few more now my
friend Talia wakes up one day full of
inspiration and writes the perfect song
for the new image the Spice Girls are
building of course it has a refrain and
pre-chorus and everything and Talia
submits the song it get analyzed and the
final score and and then the classifiers
predict the relevance
the score to the class of the benchmark
then we calculate the final score by
averaging the different predictions
according to the f1 scores of my models
and then the song gets into the Spice
Girls queue according to its core then
of course but the Spice Girls love her
song and she becomes rich and famous and
lives happily ever after or in case that
they don't work out we can see if maybe
her song got a high score in another
class and recommend Talia to submit the
song to that class so let's briefly go
through what we saw in the talk we
started by talking about motivation we
started repetition is the main feature
in songs and we defined our building
blocks cohost angry flame and after that
we talked about how we recognize the
repetition using levenshtein distance
and how we extract the repetition based
structure and the final lyrical
structure then we looked at the
different song store as song structures
and their categorization and finally we
mentioned a few musical features and so
how it's all used by the classifiers and
combined into the relevant score at my
part and of course we're hiring and I'll
finish the talk on a personal note when
I was looking for a job I didn't imagine
that my data will be songs and that we
will have meetings about type of slang
words and musical scales so basically
don't give up on finding a job that is
actually very similar to your hobbies
thank you curious to know you're trying
to money for or when suggested song is
too similar it's actually stealing or
you know it's better to be non legally
similar because it's so similar to
something that already exists we're not
doing that right now
but we are looking for repeated
sequences and there's a legal definition
of how long can be the repeated sequence
you take from another song until eighth
notes its reference and from eighth
notes its viewing
and so it's not done right now but it's
in the in the process yes so the
question is if we have a classifier for
each class for the Spice Girls for
example and no we add the Spice Girls as
a class to the data and then we train
all the classifiers again so we have the
different classes are the different
artists we're looking for songs so the
question is how do we combine the lyrics
with the melody since the lyrics
unfortunately don't come with timestamps
so it's a good question because it's
what I'm working on right now we're
actually using speech to text but it's
not best for songs you can try it it's
pretty funny and then we're doing trying
to do sequence alignment to match the
lyrics and that was inscribed lyrics and
looking for the beginning and the end of
each segment of the lyrics and for the
music we're doing segmentation from few
different tools and then we're trying to
match those two together to get the
final structure that you can actually
call a segment in the music the chorus
where did you defined by the lyrics the
question was do we share the score with
the other the author of the song no but
like I said one of the reasons that we
don't want to lose the meaning of our
features is that so we could give them
feedback that actually says you matched
for the music you had a good match but
for the lyrics not so much so maybe you
can work on your lead on your lyrics and
try to submit the song again any success
stories any success stories not yet but
you know start there writing songs and
we'll get there
as submission is the lyrics with the
music yes the submission of a song is
it's a demo where you think and we also
request for the lyrics file see these
can open up open it up pull Linux music
you can submit our also separate parts
but right now we're working mostly on
analyzing the combined part so it's not
as effective but also you can submit art
for like the cover of the song or video
for the music video and every kind of
art actually thank you
[Applause]